نعم بالنسبه لحركه المرور ما تزال متوقفه
فقط السيارات التي تاتي بجثث السوريين
الذين قضوا تحت انقاض الزلزال في انطاكيا
وفي المدن التركيه القريبه بامكاننا ان
نقترب الى المكان الذي يتم فيه تسليمه هذه
الجثث لذويهم عبر السيارات التي تاتي من
الجانب السوري التي تتسلمها من الجانب
التركي وتنقلها الى الجانب
الى الجانب السوري في هذا المكان تحديدا
عمليه نقل هذه الجثث الى الداخل الاراضي
السوريه حقيقه تواجه العائلات مصاعب كبيره
في ذلك ايضا لذلك وضمن المبادرات التطوعيه
فان الكثير من المبادرات خصص سيارات لنقل
هذه الجثث الى مدنها وبلداتها الرئيسيه
ليساره الى دف فيها بطبيعه الحال الجانب
السوري من معبر باب الهوى يتسلم جثث
السوريين من الجانب التركي ويخرجها الى
البوابه الاولى من المعبر وهنا ينتظر
عشرات الاشخاص اي خبر عن ذويهم في تركيا
هناك من يملك تنسيقا مع
السوراء له في الجانب التركي ممن نجوا من
الزلزال المدمر
ينتظر بالتالي هنا لكي يتسلم الجثه فور
وصولها وهناك اناس ينتظرون اي خبر فقط
ينتظرون هنا علا جثث ذويهم تصلوا مع هذه
الجثث لحظات صعبه حقيقه نعاينها هنا
لوصول هذه الجثه ومحاوله ذويهم التعرف
عليهم فورا وصولهم لحظات قاسيه جدا جدا
نشر معبر باب الهوى قبل قليل وعبر
الالكتروني
دليلا للسوريين في تركيا لايصال جثث ذويهم
الى هنا وبان عليهم ان يقصدوا مقبره مدينه
الريحانيه في التركيه طبعا وهناك يتم
توثيق اسماء جثث ذويهم وبعد ذلك يسلمها
الجانب التركي الى الجانب السوري
وتصل الى هنا هناك من الجثث من يصل ولا
يكون من ينتظر وصوله للاسف لان بسبب ضعف
التنسيق او بسبب
يعني عدم وجود احد من اهله هنا فيتم وضعهم
في براد داخل معبر باب الهوى الحدودي
السيارات الان ضمن المبادرات التطوعيه
تتحرك الى داخل الاراضي السوريه بعد
الدفعه جديده من جث السوريين الذين قضوا
في تركيا وبعد ان وصلت الى المعبر
وبالنسبه لحركه المعبر فانه شهد صباح هذا
اليوم وصول شاحنات تحمل مساعدات اضافيه
وهي من جمعيات تركيه كما دخل
متطوعان اسبانيان ووصلاء الى مواقع الدمار
في داخل محافظه ادلب في مدينه سلقين
تحديدا حيث شهدت هذه المدينه
تتضررت هذه المدينه بشكل كبير وهناك عده
مواقع مدمره فيها وبدا هذان المتطوعان
فعلا بحسب مصادر الدفاع المدني السوري
بالعمل مع فرق الدفاع المدني السوري لكن
في الحقيقه ما رصدناه من ردات الفعل هنا
في داخل او في على بوابه هذه المعبر ان
الناس يقولون انهم تاخروا جدا وان وصولهم
الان لا فائده منه لان لانه في اليوم
الاول والثاني من الزلزال كانت هناك اصوات
تاتي لاحياء من تحت الدمار وكانوا في ذلك
التوقيت كان يجب على المساعدات الدوليه ان
تصل وكان يجب عليها ان تتدخل لان الكثير
من من اهل وذوي الذين كانوا تحت الانقاض
كانوا يسمعون اصواتهم وكانوا لا يستطيعون
فعل اي شيء لهم وعند ذلك كانوا تركي تركوا
وحدهم ولم يتدخل احد لانقاذهم الان يبدو
ان اخراج اي احد حي من تحت الانقاض يبدو
امرا مستحيلا بعد مرور كل هذا الوقت طبعا
ما تزال فرق الدفاع المدني تعمل في عدد من
المواقع كما انها انهت العمل في المواقع
ذات التضرر الصغير كما في
الدانه وفي الجينه
وفي عده مناطق اخرى ايضا في الاتارب كان
هناك مواقع كبيره انهت متضرره انهت فرق
الدفاع المدني العمل فيها بعد اخراج اكثر
من 100 من 150
قتيلا من تحت الانقاض لكن هناك ايضا مشكله
كبيره يواجهها الدفاع المدني السوري الا
وهي ترحيل كل هذه الاكوان من الركام حتى
يتثنى له التقدم الى مراحل جديده
وشاهدنا قبل يوم امس كيف تطوع المزارعون
بجراراتهم الزراعيه لكي يقوموا بنقل هذه
الانقاض الى مسافات ابعد حتى يتمكن متطوع
الدفاع المدني السوري من العمل بسلاسه
اكبر من بعد ترحيل هذه الاتربه والاكوام
والانقاذ وبالنسبه للعالقين تحت الانقاض
ومن خلال اعمالنا في الايام الماضيه مع
ومعايناتنا لفرقه الدفاع المدني السوري
فان بعض العالقين تحت الانقاض يكونون في
فراغات تحدث داخل بيوتهم وهؤلاء يمكن لهم
ان يعيشوا لفتره داخل هذا داخل هذا المكان
وبعضهم يردم حقيقه بالاتربه والحجاره
الصغيره وهذا يكون قد فارق الحياه بشكل
سريع وبالتالي فان تدخل الفرق الانقاذ
يكونوا لاولئك الذين ما زالوا في فراغات
تحت انقاض بيوتهم وان تاخر وصول المساعده
اليهم يعني موتهم بكل تاكيد لذلك فان
المطالبه بالتدخل السريع من قبل المنقذين
ومن قبل
الجهات الدوليه كانت في اليومين الاول
والثاني والان
يعني هناك شعور بانهم تاخروا بان تدخلهم
لم يعد مجديا كثيرا
وسوف نتابع بطبيعه الحال من باب الهوى اي
تحركات ايجابيه في هذا المجال لدخول
المساعدات والدعم اللوجسي اللازم شكرا لك
صهيب الخلف من معبر باب الهوى